How's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video. In this video we are
going to talk about intracandle CISD or
the change in the state of delivery
inside a candle. So IC CISD this is a
concept that I created when I was
forming my model to mechanically define
the formation of a wick. So let's get
into the video. So first you have to
understand what a change in the state of
delivery is and that is a shift in
trend. We use that by finding the level
that hit a point of interest. So
interacting with a fair value gap, a
high or a low and then price closing
over the series of candles into that
point of interest. So here you can see
with a bullish change in the state of
delivery, price reaches, takes out this
low and then closes over the series of
down close candles that took out this
low showing a shift in trend or a change
in the state of delivery. Likewise with
this bearish scenario, it reaches into a
high, price closes through the series of
upclose candles showing the change in
trend and price shifts from bullish to
bearish. Now previously I have taught
the reversal change in the state of
delivery to confirm a swing point. So we
look for that change in the state of
delivery to form at a reversal point.
But here we are going to look at it for
a continuation to form a wick. So what
do I mean by that? If we have a candle 2
closure here, we have that reversal
change in the state of delivery on the
aligned time frame. We're anticipating
this candle 3 to open, make a low, and
then expand higher. So how did I come up
with to mechanically define the
formation of this wick being completed?
And that is a intracandle change in the
state of delivery. So, I'm looking for
inside this candle, the trend to be
bearish to go form its lower wick. And
then when that trend shifts from bearish
to bullish, that is where I'm looking
for that change in the state of delivery
inside that candle or the ICCISD.
And then I'll look to trade that
continuation higher or letting the wick
form and then trading the body. So, here
you can see this candle opens up. It has
a short-term bearish trend as it's
forming its lower wick on candle 3 here
and then I'm letting that wick form
mechanically. How do I do that? I wait
for a continuation to form. Since this
continuation forms a protected swing,
then I can anticipate this wick to be
formed. So this is the intracandle
change in the state of delivery. Inside
this candle, there was a bearish trend.
It shifts to bullish and now we are
realigned with our direction that we are
looking to trade. Anticipating this
higher time frame wick to form and to
remain intact as we continue higher. So
that is what the intracandle change in
the state of delivery is. Let's go into
trading view so we can go over a few
examples of this. So here we are in our
first example. You can see we have a
candle to closure here. We have a valid
change in the state of delivery. And
what do we have? We have a new
continuation that has formed prior to
the open of the new candle. So we'd want
to see this high remain if price is
going to trade lower. So if we're
opening up right here, where would we
want to see price react? Right here in
this fair value gap. So we'd want to see
price do what? have some sort of bullish
trend to form its upper wick, have an
intracandle change in the state of
delivery, and then get a continuation
lower. So, let's see what happens
[snorts]
here. You can see it's a bit choppy.
We're moving up into that point of
interest, and we do have a nice candle
to closure here, but what are we looking
for? We're looking for that confirmation
of the intracandle change in the state
of delivery. So, here you can see we hit
a valid point of interest by sweeping
out a high here as well as into this
fair value gap. And what do we do? We
have a closure through the series of
upclose candles into that point of
interest. So we have a valid intracandle
change in the state of delivery. So what
does that mean? That means that if I'm
considering this a protected high
intraday, that means this wick high on
the daily chart since we're on the
hourly which is aligned should remain
intact if we're going to trade lower. So
what can I do to actually act on this?
Well, I could either look to position
myself here on the hourly prior to New
York or now that I have an area to trade
away from, I can look for lower time
frame bearish entry models lower here.
But let's see what happens here. You can
see we get that expansion lower. So, you
can see how letting the wick form on
that continuation candle, letting that
intracandle change in the state of
delivery form and then looking to trade
this lower. So, this is a pretty good
example of that intracandle change in
the state of delivery, forming the wick,
and then looking to trade the body lower
into the targets below. And my indicator
does a good job of showing those
targets, which are just those previous
days lows. Let's get into another
example. So, here we are in another
example. And what do we notice here? We
have a nice candle to closure. It's
quite bearish. We have a nice V-shaped
reversal. And we just opened in candle
three. We have nice failure swing
targets below. So, what are we looking
for or what are we asking ourel? Has
candle 3 formed its wick yet? Well,
where do we want to see it form? Well,
that's where the T-spot is. And do we
have a point of interest right there? We
do. So, we can mark that out. This is
ideally where we want to see price trade
into. Why would I not want to see price
trade into this gap up here? Well,
that's too high up. I don't want to see
it trade that high because then it's
less likely to expand. So, what are we
waiting for? An intra candle change in
the state of delivery. Have we gotten
that yet? No, because price has yet to
close below this level. So I don't know
if this wick has formed yet. And here
you can see price has closed below this
level. So now with the intracandle
change in the state of delivery inside
candle 3, I can anticipate that this
high is protected and that means that
this higher time frame wick should form.
So if the wick has formed, we can look
to trade the body away. But then I could
look to take an entry on either the
retest or the close. Put my stop either
on the bodies or the high. In this case,
I'll probably use the bodies so I can
get around 2 R to this low. And then I
want to see if this gets a continuation
lower. Now, once this forms, I'm also
able to look for new continuations
within this candle.
Here you can see we do get a nice drop
through that low. Do we get a
continuation off of this? Well, what do
we want to look for? A new continuation
to form. What do we have? Price reaching
into a fair value gap. Have a new
continuation that formed. So, I could
also look for a continuation there. But
for me, since we already took out a lot
of these lows, I prefer this first
entry. But let's see what it would look
like on the second entry. In this case,
let's zoom out. Let's see what our
targets would be. Ideally, I'd want to
target into these lows. So, I would
probably look for a retest entry just to
see if I can get 2 R out of this. So,
let's see what happens if I can get 2 R
there. We'll see if we get filled.
And it looks like it would just miss us,
but you did get a continuation lower.
So, just to review this example, what
are we looking for? Well, by going back
up here, we have a candle to closure.
So, we have a bias for this candle.
Then, we're just trying to see when this
wick has formed. So, we let it open at
this candle. We couldn't say that the
wick has formed. We can't trust that.
This next candle, we also can't trust
that. on this next candle when we get
the close through. It's showing that
this candle has opened, made its high
and then formed a protected swing which
I can trade away from. Looking for this
continuation lower. So here we are in
another example and what do we have? We
have a candle 2 closure with a change in
the state of delivery and we have
displaced lower and we are opening up in
candle three. What are we going to look
for? We're going to want to ask
ourselves, has this wick formed yet? Now
mechanically we can just wait for that
intra candle change in the state of
delivery. Have we formed that yet? No.
Because we'd need to close below here.
We make a new high which gives us a
valid point of interest. What would we
need to close below? This level here. So
let's see if that forms now. And it
does. So you can see here is our first
intracandle change in the state of
delivery. The continuation inside this
higher time frame candle which forms the
wick. And then we could look to trade
that lower. And here you can see because
of how it forms, it gives great
risk-to-reward to our previous day low.
So I can get right around 2 R at that
low. Let's see if that works out. And
you can see it does hit our 2R right
there. So just to say once again, what
are we looking for? We're looking for
that continuation inside the
continuation candle to form the wick of
the higher time frame candle. Let's get
into another example. So here we are
with a candle 2 closure. And you can see
we have a V-shaped reversal, an SMT as
shown by my indicator, and we are in
candle three. If we're looking to trade
candle 3, what do we want to do? We want
to let the wick form and then trade the
body of that candle. Do we have a point
of interest? We have a fair value gap
right here in the T-spot. Let's see if
price reaches into that. So, price
immediately goes lower into a target
here. Let's see if we get a retracement
or a reversal. Here we get a little
consolidation and a move up into that
point of interest. Now with the ICISD,
it is ideal to have this form in the
beginning of the candle. So this candle
can really expand lower. Here you can
see we have taken most of the candle's
time and quite a bit range. Right? We
make a move lower, a move higher, and
now a move lower again to form. So if we
do form this change in the state of
delivery intra candle or the ICCSD,
right? It's ideal to wait for the next
candle to trade this. And here you can
see we do get that. Why would we want to
wait for the next candle? Because we get
a new candle with new range. We now have
another hour for this candle to expand.
So here I could look to take this entry.
Either put my stop here, put it on the
high and look for 2 R. Or I could also
wait for what? A new intracandle change
in the state of delivery or the wick
formation of candle 4. In this case,
we'll just take an entry there. See if
it will work out. We'll look for a
retest entry so we can get decent
risk-to-reward. And there you can see we
do get that retest entry and a move
lower. So what can we learn from this
example? It's more ideal if the
intracandle change in the state of
delivery happens early into the candle
so it can expand. If it happens towards
the end of the candle and it's still
valid, then I'm going to be looking for
the next candle to have that expansion
as it gives new range. So here we are in
another example. You can see we have a
candle 2 closure and we are opening up
right with a point of interest right
here. So ideally what would we want to
see price open make a high this is a
short-term or a lower time frame bullish
trend shift that trend with an
intracandle change in the state of
delivery and then get a continuation
lower. Once again it's ideal if it forms
early into the candle so it can trend
lower. Let's see what happens.
And here you can see we reach into that
point of interest. Do we get the
closure? Not yet. And if you seen my
continuation video, ideally we get it on
this next candle. Or if it spends too
long consolidating, then it could fail.
Let's see. And there we get that
continuation. So I could look to take a
short setup, put my stop on the high,
look for a continuation lower. If that
doesn't give me good risk-to-reward, I
can always look for a little bit of a
retest to get to R. And you can see we
form a new continuation. And does this
trend lower?
takes a bit of time, but it does. So,
you can see how that protected swing
inside candle 3 here forms the wick high
of that candle 3. And the same thing
here with candle 4. You can see candle
4, what does it do? Reach into a point
of interest or a fair value gap. Price
closing over this level. That confirms
the wick of candle 4 right there. And
then it gets that continuation lower. So
there's not just an intracandle change
in the state of delivery in candle 3,
but it's also in candle 4. So let's go
ahead and zoom out to the daily chart
and see if we can find one more example.
So we'll wait for a candle 2 closure on
the daily and let's see there we found
one. Let's go in here and see if we can
find an intracandle change in the state
of delivery. So here we have a candle to
closure, right? We have a bit of a
range. And what are we looking for?
Well, we'd want to see price reach into
a point of interest. If price is opening
up here, what is our point of interest?
Running out these lows here. So, let's
see what happens.
It runs out the highs first, goes
aggressively against our bias, and
that's okay, right? You can either
invalidate your bias. I wouldn't
invalidate my bias because it's not a
reversal off of previous day high, but
I'd want to wait for a new continuation.
So, I either need this to get bought up
rather quickly to form a candle three
closure and then look for that to trade
higher or I need some sort of
consolidation and new sweep because I
need a new point of interest.
You can see that is more of a
consolidation. Really hard to trust this
level here. So, I need another sweep.
And who knows, maybe this one will fail.
And there you can see we do get that
aggressive move out. So, now what do we
have? we have a continuation that has
formed inside our candle three. So now
I've anticipate that this wick has
formed on the daily time frame. So I
could look to trade it higher. What is
my target that daily high there? So
ideally putting my stop on the low and
being able to get to R to that high
which is right around a retest entry. So
we'll see if we get tagged in and if not
we don't. And we don't get tagged in and
that's okay, right? We could look for a
higher time frame target. That's okay. I
was looking for 2R to this short-term
target. Now, I hope you enjoyed this
video and it taught you how to let the
wick form and then trade the body. And
if you don't have the patience to let
that wick form, then generally you
become the wick.
If you are looking for a way to work
more closely with me and get more
one-on-one support within your trading,
you can click the link below. We have a
wait list for our program so you can
join and I will let you know when we
have new openings. Have a good one.